[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how's everybody doing today alright okay
so today I'm talking a little bit about
compilers and why I think they're at the
core of the next evolution of web
performance as I mentioned my name is
Chad I tell I'm a senior staff software
engineer at LinkedIn where I get to work
on a bunch of open-source JavaScript
infrastructure that help power
LinkedIn's applications I'm also part of
the Emer j/s core team where I help
maintain and work on different libraries
and frameworks within the Ember
ecosystem you have any questions about
LinkedIn or ember come find me after my
talk but Before we jump into my talk we
first have to have a baseline
understanding of what actually is a
compiler and I think this topic can be
rather intimidating for a lot of people
because as associated with things like
computer science and theory and not
everybody has a background in those
things so when I think about a compiler
and what it is at a high level what it
really is is that it's really just a
code translator
it's gonna take some source code in the
compilers in a transformer in various
different ways and what you're gonna get
as output is another executable program
so for instance and the browser you can
write something like this a super simple
add one function and what the browser
has to do before it can actually execute
this function is parse and compile it
into something that's much more
low-level something that can actually
run on top of a CPU and it's the
browser's ability to do this just
just-in-time compilation that has made
the web a viable platform for building
very sophisticated applications but I'm
not actually here today to talk about
these compilers I'm here to talk about
the compilers that we use every single
day inside of our tool chains and we've
actually been using compilers for quite
a long period of time about 15 years or
so
maybe a little bit more and so we're
going to quickly look through kind of
the history of compilers in the front
and tooling space and what they've
afforded us and
terms of like performance or developer
ergonomics so we first have to go back
to 2003 when Douglas Crockford writes
Jasmine and Jasmine is a one file cc
library that just removed all the
meaningless white space from your
JavaScript code and things like comments
and stuff like that and this drastically
shrunk the size of the applications that
we were shipping to the browser right
along the same period of time Yui
compressor comes out and right Yui
compressor has this very similar type of
goals it wants to reduce the size of the
JavaScript that's being sent over the
wire and it does things like removing
this meaningless whitespace and removing
comments but it introduces the notion of
mangling or symbol mangling and it goes
something like this so this is a unique
and functional
2003 this is like ballad es 3 code and
so what the compiler is gonna do is that
it's gonna pull out all of the user
identify or user specified identifiers
so this is unique our red-eye item and
what the compiler does is it Maps them
onto a set of new identifiers in this
case a b c d and e and it can do this
because the compiler has all the lexical
and semantic information inside of it so
it knows that it safely can remap this
thing that you wrote into something that
is much smaller and so while in 2018
this is not like a new novel idea
anybody that's building JavaScript
applications is going through a
minification step but at the time this
was rather novel and it sped up
applications quite a bit next comes this
period from 2003 to 2008 and not a whole
lot happens during this time in terms of
like developer tool chains and
everything like that and that's because
this is the life and death of es 4 and
so for those who are familiar with what
es 4 is or was it was an actual
specification of JavaScript that never
actually shipped but looking back at es
4 today we would actually say that es 4
has shipped because it specified things
like cloud
module system generators iterators
destructuring assignment all the things
that we're using today inside of our
applications but mind you this is
developers wanted these types of
features from the language back then and
this is also when Google comes out with
Google Maps and kind of shows the types
of things that we can build it build for
the web and we can be a little bit more
ambitious in terms of the applications
that we want to build there so next
comes this period from 2008 to 2010 and
what do we see during this period of
time well we actually see like an
explosion of compilers enter the tooling
space and actually like to call this
period of time the Enlightenment it's
kind of like the origin story of where
we are today from a tooling perspective
so we have projects like cappuccino GWT
and CoffeeScript that are all kind of
birthed out of the sentiment that they
no longer run be beholden to the
standardization process so in case of
cappuccino they create objective J which
is a dialect of Objective C GWT bothers
borrows Java and CoffeeScript and takes
the best parts of Python and Ruby to
create a new language and what all these
projects kind of have in common is that
they are their own language and they
build sophisticated compilers in between
there to turn that language into
JavaScript code that could run in the
browser of the time and so this allowed
them to do things like shed away runtime
libraries for doing things like class
systems but the big idea here is that
javascript is effectively a bytecode
format you don't actually have to write
in the programming language of the web
as long as you can build the
sophisticated enough compiler that map's
the what the language that you wrote in
on to the semantics of the JavaScript
language the other thing that comes out
during this period of time is more
advanced minifiers so this is closure
compiler and closure compiler is pretty
unique so let's say you have some
JavaScript code in your application like
this this is very silly code but in a
large-enough application you will end up
having code like this even if you try
really hard so we can see that like
predicate is never actually getting
reassigned
so the first conditional is always going
to execute the second conditional is
never going to execute and then we have
this do stuff function declaration here
where we're just something left and
right and we've left off callback and
then last time we're doing some type of
string interpolation it's drink
interpolation or concatenation type of
thing so if you give this code to a
closure compiler what you get out of it
is something like this so not only has
it minified the code it has done a whole
lot more so the closure compiler can
figure out that this first branch is
always going to execute so just in line
the body of the conditional the second
conditional was never going to execute
so just throw it away and then the
interesting part here is that do stuff
just doesn't exist so closure compiler
has this technique in it known as
concept folding where it can see if
calls to the function are going to be
side-effect free it can just do that
work in ahead of time and just inline
the result it's also done the same thing
with a and B here where it is just
concatenated them into the string
because there is no observable
side-effects and so because closure
compiler takes in your entire
application and produces this more
optimal subset of the code what we
actually call closure compiler is an
optimizing compiler it's a really cool
piece of technology and it's still used
today on a lot of web properties and so
that brings us to today and I think
today we have like really great tools we
have web pack we have roll-up
we had tracer for some period of time
but like babel is kind of superseded in
turn in translation space and so what
are those tools doing well they're
actually building off the backs that
things of the things that came before it
so in the case they allow you to use it
like new language features which kind of
harkens back to the sentiment of like
the objective J's and the coffee scripts
of the world they can do more optimized
code bundles they can do different forms
of dead code elimination so this is like
scope poising and tree shaking and so
you'd think in 2018 we're kind of like
pinnacle of performance here we've had
15 years of really sophisticated tool
chains being developed so everything is
great
right well I actually say that there are
quite a few problems in what we do today
I think that's because we've kind of
fundamentally changed on how we approach
to building applications for the web and
so this is a tweet by Alex Russell who
is a developer on the chrome team he
also might be some of you guys
colleagues and what he says is the web
is getting slower because no matter how
much faster we make Chrome developers
abuse users with ever larger piles of
JavaScript and JavaScript is the most
expensive thing so let me unpack this a
little bit so I think about five years
ago we kind of shifted quite drastically
and how we approach to building web
applications we used to start with HTML
and then you style it with CSS and then
you would layer on the JavaScript to get
a little bit of interactivity and we've
basically inverted this world we start
with JavaScript a lot of the times and
we add CSS to it and hTML is this out of
the picture for a lot of applications
nowadays and so because we are pushing
more and more responsibility onto
JavaScript there tends to be a lot more
of it and we have to ship that down to
our users and what he's talking about
in this last part about JavaScript being
the most expensive thing is this it is
the parse and compile step of JavaScript
that is very very expensive so if you
think about it you're writing JavaScript
code it's the textual representation
that code needs to go to the browser and
needs to turn into an executable like
thing like it just doesn't run the text
that you wrote and so in 2017 addy
osmani wrote a really great blog article
called JavaScript startup time and he
had this really great graphic in it and
what it's saying is that the bytes of
JavaScript are not the same bytes as a
jpg and so this is on a constrained
network and a constraint is a device so
if you have 170 KB of anything it takes
roughly the same amount of time to pull
it over the wire so in this case it
takes three and a half seconds to
transmit both of these asset types but
once they get on to the device it's a
whole nother ballgame so in the case of
a JPEG it is binary data so it just
goes through a decoder like pretty
quickly and it takes about 70
milliseconds to do that whereas the
JavaScript takes an additional two
seconds for it just the process on the
device and I think this is some of the
stuff that both Chris and Malte we're
talking about two days ago and then from
there the JavaScript then executes for
another 1/2 seconds whereas the JPEG
just needs to paint of the screen takes
point 0 to 8 mills are 2.8 milliseconds
AG are seconds to do that so very
different types of resources that we're
talking about here and so as I mentioned
I'm on the ember.js core team and over
the past couple years I've been working
on this project known as the glimmer VM
and we think about the glimmer being at
VM as an example of the types of tools
that I think that we have to start
thinking about building or building to
help mitigate some of these inherent
problems with JavaScript and so for
those who are familiar with what the
glimmer VM is it is the rendering engine
inside of ember and this is the San
Diego ember meetups mascot it's pretty
cool so for those who are familiar with
what it means to build an ember
application I'm going to go through a
really quick example so this is your
quintessential to do MVC type of app so
you would have a - duze component you
would each over each one of the two dues
every iteration of the loop
you're gonna invoke an item component
and you're past the to do at that index
into the item component item component
is what we call a template only
component if you're familiar with
reactor solutions like it we would call
it a pure component it just draws from
its inputs and then the backing class
for the - dues component would look
something like this we have a couple
different decorators here tract is just
our mechanism for doing change detection
in the system and action is this binding
the instance - basically doing the bind
so that when we put it into the template
layer you can just freely pass it around
so this isn't all that important but the
important part is that ember uses
templates and it's one of the large
just reasons why it broke away from this
other framework which was known as
sprout core which is used to build like
things like mobile me at Apple it was to
bring this declarative templating
language to a framework and we're not
actually alone in this philosophy of
having a domain-specific language to
declaratively declaratively describe our
views and something that actually isn't
in JavaScript both of you and angular
have I think a very similar philosophy
and angular actually wrote pretty
extensively about why angular uses
templates in 2016 it's a really great
blog article but at the end of the day
even though that view and angular are
owning complete languages with our own
semantics and their own compiler stacks
at the end of the day both view and
angular still compile the templates to
JavaScript and so it's not really
working towards solving this parse and
compile problem or problem or just
property of JavaScript so how does
glimmr VM approach this problem well
instead of compiling the templates to
JavaScript we actually compile them to a
binary executable anytime that you're
talking about binary like we have to
have the matrix background so what does
that actually mean that means if you
write a template like this at Build time
so this is ahead of time compilation
step we compile that template into a
binary blob that encodes all of the
instructions to recreate that template
at runtime and so you may be saying to
yourself ah this is like quite novel but
how does it actually help mitigate this
parse and compile problem
well binary data in the browser is can
be represented by an API known as a
typed array if you go find the
documentation for a typed array you'll
come across this great definition that
says a typed array is a slab of memory
with a type view into it much like how
arrays work and see because of typed
array is backed by raw memory the
JavaScript engine can pass that memory
directly to native libraries without
having to painstakingly convert the data
into a native representation so what
it's talking about and that last part is
parsing a pile
with typed arrays and the data inside of
them they never actually see the parse
and compile pipeline of JavaScript so
that's a pretty cool property of them so
if we look at open source java open
source ember applications and even
internal applications what we tend to
find is anywhere from 25 to 40 percent
of these applications are built up of
this templating layer and so if we can
take those templates and compile them
into something that isn't JavaScript
that doesn't have these inherent parse
and compile not issues but it's just the
reality of the world then what we can do
is we can actually speed up applications
so how do we actually do this we're
gonna kind of walk through kind of a
quick example of how both the
compilation part works and then how we
actually execute that code at runtime so
valid HTML in handlebars templates is
valid a valid template so we're going to
use this super simple hello world
esque example to kind of walk through
the process so the first thing that
we're actually going to do is we're
gonna take that template and we're going
to tokenize it into an abstract syntax
tree and then it's gonna get passed
through a couple different compilers
stages and at the end of the day what
you're gonna get out of this phase is
something that looks like this so we
started with this declarative templating
layer and now what we get is like this
JSON that is very declarative it title
looks like the message format that the
worker Dom uses and so this is JSON this
isn't actually binary so we actually
have to further compile this format down
and that's where the OP code compiler
comes in before we actually jump into
what the role of the OpCo compiler is
let me unpack some terminology so an
opcode is just a number a number that is
significant to a virtual machine that is
tied to some level or a small bit of
functionality so you can think of it as
just a function that is going to do a
little bit of work
and an opcode takes operands and you can
think of operands is just arguments to
that function and together you would
call this an instruction a bytecode set
is just many instructions that is
encoding where these instructions begin
and end so it's just a bunch of numbers
but those numbers are encoded in a very
specific way so going back to our JSON
example we're going to start compiling
this into that binary format so the
first thing that we do is that we're
going to pop each item off of this list
so in this case we're going to compile
open out the open element statement
we're gonna map that the first element
of that array into a method of the same
name so open element maps into an open
Ellyn element method and then it's going
to take some arguments here for open
element it's gonna take the tag name and
the first thing that we actually do here
is that we push the tag name into a
strings constants pool the constants
pool is this gonna hold on to our
user-defined literals in the system and
from that we're gonna get a number in
this case that's the first thing that
we're pushing in so we'll get 0 out of
the the constants pool and so tag is 0
at this point and then we pass that into
the stop builder open element so because
the VM is working on these op codes and
they're just numbers we create an
abstraction around those numbers so
almost like a DSL type of type of thing
that's holding on to you know the
significant numbers in the VM this way
so you're not like hard coding you know
45 36 all over the place we have like an
abstraction on that and the purpose of
that abstraction is just to create this
linear list of numbers and so at the end
of this compilation what what do we get
we get a linear list of numbers and then
we get this JSON map thing that is just
the user-defined literals in the system
and that's it that's the basically the
entire process of compiling this from
this a declarative template language all
the way to a binary format so next comes
actually executing this thing
before we get into executing I probably
should unpack what a virtual machine is
a virtual machine is a CPU written in in
software but at the end of the day what
you can really think of it as is just a
while loop with a switch statement
inside of it and every time you iterate
that loop you're pointing at an
instruction that you need to execute and
then that that opcode is goes into the
switch and then the switch disc
dispatches the instruction so that's
probably the easiest way of explaining a
virtual machine so because we're dealing
with binary data we actually use the
fetch API in the browser and so we asked
for the templates to come back as an
array buffer and then we just take that
array buffer and we pass it into a UN 16
array which is a typed array and that's
it that's that's how we get the
executable into the virtual machine so
this is kind of my visualization of what
is actually going on inside the inside
of the VM the VM works on like an
iterator type of pattern so you drive
the state forward you're iterating the
internal loop by just calling next from
the outside and then on the right we
kind of have a bunch of different state
here so the top is the executable that
we compiled and below that is our
constants pool and then we have some
registers here and you can think of
registers as just basically you could
think of them as like an object that's
holding on to state that we're going to
consult as the VM is running so we have
a constructing register and that
register is going to hold on to HTML
elements as we are building them PC is
program counter or in other virtual
machines you call an instruction pointer
and it's always this pointing at the
instruction that's currently being
executed and then we have our a which is
a return address for this presentation
it's gonna stain negative 1 but because
of the VM has components in it
components are modeled like function
calls so after you call into a function
you need to come you need to know where
you're going
once you've done executing it that's
what that registers for typically used
for and then we have a couple different
stacks there's an execution stack which
isn't shown here because you don't need
it for this example
and then there's an element stack which
is just going to hold on to our HTML
elements once they've been constructed
so we're gonna walk through this example
step by step to show how we actually
execute this binary format the other
thing I'll also note is that we have the
code the actual code that is being
executed when we were doing this and
what you'll find is the code is not all
that much so the first thing that we are
going to execute is open element open
element is 31 and it takes one operand
and that operand is 0 in this case 0 is
used to be the index into the constants
pool and so what it does is it pulls out
the string h1 it creates a HTML heading
element and places it on to the
constructing register the next step is
flush element now if there is actual
attributes on this HTML element there
would have been more instructions
between open element and flushing the
element but since there were none
we immediately flushed the element from
the constructing register and we just
put it on to the element stack next is
text text is pretty simple it's going to
pop the element at the head of the
element stack off create a text node
append it and then push it back on to
the stack and I guess yeah it's 26 + 1
is this pointing at the first item
inside of the constants pool so it knows
how to pick up hello Chad next is close
element what close element does is it
just takes the element that's at the
head of the stack and appends it to the
dom and then finally we return and what
return does is it just sets the the
return address to the program counter
which sets it to negative 1 negative 1
is our way in the system to say
basically halt there is no more
instructions to actually execute and
that's that's pretty much it that's how
we take this binary format and actually
turn it into a working UI so we really
think about the glimmer VM as a
declarative programming language for
creating you eyes and the glimmer VM is
a virtual machine in byte code format
for constructing those you eyes so you
may have also heard of this thing called
web assembly and it is quote/unquote a
bytecode for the web so what how does
this like relate to the thing that
you're building
well web assembly is more of like a
portable binary format than it is
anything really to do with the web right
now so for example you cannot call
web-based api's inside of web assembly
it's really good for number crunching
and doing these types of really awesome
demos like porting the unity gaming
engine to to the web but it's still
pretty interesting it has a lot of cool
properties associated with it so some of
those properties are how it did how its
actually process on the client so on the
top here we have JavaScript and
JavaScript goes through parse and
compile stuff and then goes through an
optimization step if the code because
JavaScript is a dynamic language you can
deopt as you're running it so then you
have to reoptimize it and throwing away
any optimized code that you you have it
has to execute and then you have you
have to GC at certain points of time
whereas web assembly it parses and
compiles directly to optimized code it
has no optimizing the when you actually
compile it it compiles into the most
optimized code and it cannot deopt
and that's because you it is a compile
target and you're taking languages that
have static type information you're
compiling it into something that is
strong guarantees around it the other
thing that that's really great about web
assembly here is that you get it has the
ability to compile faster than it is to
download so it has a streaming compiler
a streaming parser and compiler and
javascript has this also but like like
almost like the JPEG format it's already
closer to the binary format so
it can happen much quicker the other
thing is about webassembly is that it
has predictable performance and this
kind of goes back to the Diop tree
optimization step I'm not sure how many
people saw this blog article where
Mozilla took the source map library and
converted parts of it to rust and then
compiled the web assembly and got some
like ridiculous performance benefits out
of it because of the code being like
highly could be highly polymorphic now
you can write highly tuned JavaScript
code to get to that same level of
performance but not everybody is a
browser engineer and knows all the fast
paths inside of the actual JavaScript
engine so webassembly kind of alleviates
having to know all of those details but
one of the issues with web assembly is
that you typically have to write in a
systems like language so C C++ rust and
then compile them to web assembly and I
don't know about you guys but this is
not what I do in my day to day job I'm
not writing C C simple C++ or rust
applications so we we kind of it's kind
of a high bar to a new entrance I think
right now but I don't think it actually
has to be or we we can use the fact that
we have things inside the JavaScript
ecosystem where we can get the benefit
without actually having to directly
write rust or C++ or any of those other
languages and that's because in within
the web community we actually have quite
a few domain-specific languages already
and those domain-specific languages and
the runtimes for them are already
written in JavaScript and so if we can
pour the the runtimes of these languages
to web assembly then we as people that
work with JavaScript there and building
things for the web can immediately get
the benefit of them without actually
having to learn how that stuff actually
works so earlier this year we worked
with
folks at Mozilla and a couple people
from there Russ core team to figure out
how we can utilize web assembly inside
of the glimmer VM so these are kind of
all the high-level components of the
goomar VM and what we notice is that all
this stuff on the bottom
the registers the opcodes the stack the
heap the constants the execution are all
things that if we were writing the VM
and for any other platform you would
probably pick a C C++ rust type of
language and so what we did was that we
took those implementations that were
written in JavaScript and we wrote them
and rust and compiled them to web
assembly and everything just worked so
we were able to drop that into an
existing ember we were able to like take
this branch build it and then drop this
version in the glimmer VM directly into
an existing ember application and that
ember application can run the web
assembly under the hood the end consumer
as you are like the developer the person
that wrote the application has no idea
that this actually occurred and you can
get the benefits that are I think now
starting to really land inside of web
assembly so these are all the ways I
think we're actually thinking about the
startup performance of applications it's
a pretty tricky problem because you
don't actually notice like parse and
compile problems when you're first
building your application and your first
couple features or even when you first
launch your application it's a problem
that sneaks up on you over time and like
we we don't do a very good job at
testing the whole Rea of devices for
making sure that our JavaScript startup
performance is always top notch so
hopefully today I showed that we
actually have the technology to help
mitigate a lot of these problems we just
have to think I think a little bit
different about how we're approaching
our problems and just in development in
general so that's it Thanks
[Applause]